.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Guten Abend.
Grüezi.
- Guten Abend.
Bonjour Madame, bonjour Monsieur.
- Bonjour.
Bitte, kommen Sie herein.
- Merci, grazie.
Buonasera, Signor Mengstab,
benvenuti.
Gut, bevor wir
zum eigentlichen Thema kommen
und Ihnen einige Fragen stellen,
möchten wir wissen,
weshalb Sie Schweizer werden wollen.
Mit der C-Bewilligung können Sie
hier in der Schweiz bleiben.
Was hat Sie bewogen,
Schweizer werden zu wollen?
Während der Anhörung kam ich mir vor
wie bei einer Inquisition.
Ja, es ist wie bei einer Prüfung.
Eine Prüfung bestehe ich oder nicht.
Ich gebe das Wort meinen Kollegen.
Wir wussten,
dass es 13 Personen sein werden,
aber nicht,
welche Fragen sie uns stellen.
Es gibt Bewerber,
die nicht einmal wissen,
wie das Viertel heisst,
in dem sie wohnen.
Können wir?
Warum wollen Sie Schweizer werden?
Auch wenn du vieles weisst,
bist du nie sicher, ob du
alle Fragen beantworten kannst.
Der rote Pass
soll einen gewissen Wert haben.
Er soll ein Gipfel sein,
den man erklimmen will.
Wir vergeben den Schweizer Pass
nicht leichtfertig.
Ich finde es normal,
dass es so abläuft.
Das Schweizer Einbürgerungsverfahren
ist das strengste in ganz Europa.
Zwar gibt es
nur einen Schweizer Pass,
aber über 2'000 Wege,
ihn zu bekommen.
Das entspricht
der Anzahl Gemeinden in unserem Land.
Zum ersten Mal haben kommunale
Behörden in allen vier Sprachregionen
Zutritt zu ihren sehr vertraulichen
Anhörungen gewährt.
Beim entscheidenden Schritt
vor der Kommission
müssen die Bewerber/-innen
ihre Swissness unter Beweis stellen
und zeigen, dass sie das Räderwerk,
das unser Land antreibt,
bis ins kleinste Detail kennen.
Willkommen
in der Einbürgerungsfabrik,
willkommen
bei "Fabrique des Suisses",
"Far Svizers",
"La Fabbrica degli Svizzeri",
"Schweizer machen".
* Kirchenglocken *
* Sanfte, hallende Saitenmusik *
So, guten Morgen miteinander.
Heute ist Grosskampftag.
Vom Ablauf her wird es so sein:
Wir stellen zwei Buffets auf,
die Bar steht wie gewöhnlich hinten.
Getränke? Alles klar, denke ich.
Gläser? Gut.
Ich bin Bürger
von Pontresina und Valendas.
Ich bin in Pontresina aufgewachsen.
Ich bin Hotelier
der Hotels Walther und Steinbock,
die ich gemeinsam mit meiner Frau
in dritter Generation
seit nun 23 Jahren führe.
Wollen Sie schauen,
welchen Tisch Sie
im Speisesaal reserviert haben?
Ich denke, jeder, der will,
der die Werte vertritt
und mit unseren Wertvorstellungen
leben will,
kann Schweizer Bürger werden.
Diese sind alle herzlich willkommen.
Wenn jemand das nicht will,
geht es einfach nicht.
Dann haben wir die Mechanismen,
um das zu verhindern.
* Sphärische Musik *
Wir sind
eine klassische Tourismusregion.
Etwa 70 % unserer Mitarbeiter/-innen
sind Ausländer.
Mittlerweile
sind zwölf Nationen vertreten.
Ohne die Ausländer
würde es gar nicht gehen.
Ohne Thomas Walther
wäre Pontresina nicht Pontresina.
Der Hotelier
ist Präsident der Bürgergemeinde.
Er sitzt
in etlichen Verwaltungsräten.
V.a. aber ist er
einer der grössten Arbeitgeber
der äusserst touristischen
Berggemeinde.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass meine Grosseltern
fast ausschliesslich italienische
Gastarbeiter eingestellt hatten.
Dann schwappte die Welle
mehr Richtung Spanien über
und dann in Richtung Ex-Jugoslawien.
Momentan
ist Portugal sehr stark vertreten.
Fast alle Schweizer wissen auch,
dass der Wohlstand der Schweiz
nicht per se
von Schweizern erarbeitet wurde.
Den Gotthard und die Autobahnen
haben wenige Schweizer gebaut.
Die ganze Wirtschaft läuft so,
weil das Land viel zu klein ist,
um alles selber zu erarbeiten.
Das kann nicht sein -
es funktioniert nicht.
Es kommt kein Bier heraus.
Unser Ziel ist,
v.a. Jugendliche oder z.T. auch
Kinder von Familien einzubürgern,
die schon lange
in Pontresina leben, arbeiten
und sehr gut integriert sind.
Viele Kinder wurden in Pontresina
geboren, gehen hier zur Schule,
sprechen Deutsch,
Rätoromanisch oder Italienisch.
Diesen wollen wir Wurzeln geben.
Im kleinen Ferienort mit
2'000 Einwohnern kennt jeder jeden.
Und wer sich einbürgern lassen will,
kennt Thomas Walther.
Auch für Familie Corona-Cardoso
führt kein Weg an ihm vorbei.
In ein paar Monaten
wird er sie anhören.
Ist das wieder Cola?
- Das hilft mir beim Verdauen.
Ich habe
viel zu viel Rösti gegessen.
Gegen vier oder fünf Uhr
solltest du verdauen, Chiara.
Genau das fehlt dir noch.
Alles andere ist schon gemacht.
Okay?- Gut so.
Nach 30 Jahren im Engadin
hat sich die
italienisch-portugiesische Familie
doch noch dazu entschlossen,
sich einbürgern zu lassen.
Ana und Paolo sind bereit
für das schier endlose Verfahren.
Pontresina ist mein Lieblingsdorf.
Hier habe ich
meinen Mann kennengelernt.
Das bleibt immer in meinem Herzen.
Nach 30 Jahren
fühle ich mich hier zu Hause.
Das ist meine zweite Heimat.
Wenn du siehst, dass du so gut
integriert bist und Freude hast,
ist es schade,
dass du ohne Schweizer Pass
nicht abstimmen kannst.
Für uns
ist es ein bisschen kompliziert.
Mein Mann braucht Dokumente
aus Italien, ich aus Portugal.
Unsere Tochter
wurde in der Schweiz geboren.
Wir müssen viel organisieren.
... vom portugiesischen Konsulat
in Rom?
Nein, wir haben alles
in Mailand machen lassen.
Ein Schriftstück fehlt immer noch.
Um an das Dokument zu kommen,
setzt Ana auf eine
bestens organisierte Gemeinschaft.
Der Konsul von Portugal
kommt regelmässig aus Zürich
bei den Portugiesen im Engadin
vorbei.
Er hat sein mobiles Büro mit dabei.
Für die portugiesische Gemeinschaft
im Engadin
ist das eine grosse Unterstützung.
So kannst du
viel Zeit und Spesen sparen.
* Sie spricht portugiesisch. *
Nach so vielen Jahren hier
fühle ich mich schon
als Schweizerin -
nur der Pass fehlt noch.
Uns erleichtert der Schweizer Pass
nicht einfach nur das Leben.
Uns gibt er das Gefühl,
noch besser
in die Schweiz integriert zu sein.
Ähm ... Ich fühle mich nicht als
Schweizerin, ich bin Pontresinerin.
* Sphärische, glockige Musik *
Ich brauchte einen Geburtsschein
und unsere Heiratsurkunde.
Ich habe vor über einem Monat bei
meiner Heimatgemeinde nachgefragt.
Zum Glück
kenne ich dort noch ein paar Leute,
sonst kann sich das
in die Länge ziehen.
Für Paolo ist es nur ein
kurzer Abstecher in sein Heimatland.
Die Gemeinde,
in der er aufgewachsen ist,
liegt auf der anderen Seite
des Berninapasses, in Italien.
Dort hatte er auch mit Ana gewohnt,
als sie frisch zusammengezogen waren.
Damals, als Grenzgänger, haben sie
täglich 120 km zurückgelegt -
bei jedem Wetter.
Im Winter gab es immer viel Verkehr
und viel Schnee.
Nach einem langen Arbeitstag
die Strecke müde zurückzulegen,
um nach Hause zu kommen,
das war hart.
Aber wir waren jung und naiv.
In diesen Jahren haben wir
ziemlich viel auf uns genommen,
nur für die Arbeit.
Wir wollten wissen, wie es ist,
in der Schweiz zu arbeiten.
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik *
Schau, wie das Wetter wechselt.
Hier ist schon fast Frühling.
Für mich ist das Veltlin
eine andere Welt.
Hier bin ich aufgewachsen.
Im Veltlin
ist vieles besser organisiert
als im restlichen Italien.
Hier sind deine Urkunden.
- Grazie mille.
Grazie della ...
... della tu...
Non lo so.
Ich bin erst seit zwei Tagen
Bürgermeister
und schon habe ich
etwas Wichtiges erreicht.
Bene, perfetto. Ti ringrazio ancora.
Ciao, grazie. Ciao, merci.
Nach so langer Zeit in der Schweiz
haben wir doch mehr verdient
als nur die Arbeit, oder?
Ganz anders als in Graubünden
ist die Sichtweise im Kanton Tessin.
Bei fast 70'000 Grenzgängern täglich
werden Ausländer anders wahrgenommen.
Ich heisse Dawit Mengstab,
ich stamme aus Eritrea.
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt und lebe seit
fast zwölf Jahren in der Schweiz.
Ich bin Verkäufer im Mediamarkt.
Ich war im Krieg gegen Äthiopien
und habe für mein Land gekämpft.
Dabei wurde ich verletzt.
Ich habe mein Blut
für Eritrea gegeben.
Meine Grosseltern haben 30 Jahre
lang gegen Äthiopien gekämpft.
Sie sind nicht geflüchtet.
Auch meine Freunde
führen den Kampf weiter.
Ich nicht - ich musste weg.
Nach zehn Jahren Militärdienst
hat sich Dawit dazu durchgerungen,
aus Eritrea zu flüchten,
wo die Kämpfe andauern.
Er musste
seine ganze Familie zurücklassen,
als er sich
für ein Leben im Exil entschied.
Wenn du daran denkst,
aus Eritrea zu fliehen,
rechnest du nicht damit,
dass der Weg so hart sein wird.
Am härtesten
waren die Sahara und das Meer.
In der Wüste, ohne Wasser
hältst du keinen halben Tag durch.
Wenn du einen Freund, ein Kind, eine
Frau in der Wüste sterben siehst,
dann denkst du daran, umzukehren -
aber du kannst nicht.
Wer kehrt schon um?
Wenn jemand
auf dem Meer im Boot stirbt,
nimmst du ihn nicht
bis nach Italien mit,
sondern wirfst ihn über Bord.
Wir fragen uns,
wie human die Situation ist.
Du machst
die ganze Reise durch Libyen
mit einem Jungen,
der unterwegs stirbt.
Du wirfst ihn ins Meer,
noch bevor du Italien erreicht hast.
Was hat das für einen Sinn?
Dein Körper
ist zwar in Italien angekommen,
aber deine Seele
erholt sich niemals.
Nach zweieinhalb Jahren Ungewissheit
erhielt Dawit den Flüchtlingsstatus
und beantragte den Familiennachzug.
Seine Frau und seine Tochter
konnten zu ihm nach Lugano reisen.
Seither
sind noch zwei Söhne dazugekommen.
Heute besitzt er einen C-Ausweis.
Vor Kurzem
hat er für sich und seine Familie
ein Einbürgerungsgesuch gestellt.
* Sphärische Musik *
Für Dawit bedeutete die Schweiz
Genf und die Menschenrechte.
Doch als er im Tessin ankam,
stand der Kanton unter dem Einfluss
der Lega dei Ticinesi
und deren sehr restriktiver
Einwanderungspolitik.
Dawit wird das
hautnah zu spüren bekommen.
Seit über 25 Jahren
sitzt ein Lega-Mitglied
der kommunalen
Einbürgerungskommission vor.
Politik ist meine Leidenschaft.
Die Tessiner Lega
hat mir Raum geschaffen.
Von der CVP
hatte ich mich enttäuscht abgewandt.
Zu der Zeit waren meine Eltern
mit Giuliano Bignasca befreundet.
Und so kam ich zur Lega.
* Lauernde elektronische Musik *
Im Kanton Tessin ist Wahltag.
Enea Petrini
ist unterwegs zu seinem Stammtisch,
um die Ergebnisse zu erfahren.
Für mich
hat diese Kampagne zwei Aspekte:
zum einen die Ergebnisse
im Staatsrat und im Grossen Rat,
die sind natürlich wichtig.
Zum anderen erlebe ich die Wahl aber
auch auf einer persönlicheren Ebene,
weil ich selbst für einen Sitz
im Grossen Rat kandidiere.
Morgen weiss ich,
ob ich wiedergewählt wurde.
Die Lega soll hochleben.
- Lega für immer.
Und gewinnen.
Morgen soll sie aufs Titelblatt.
Die Lega war eine Bewegung
der Unzufriedenen.
Klar ist es einfacher,
die Unzufriedenen zu bewegen
als die Zufriedenen.
Inzwischen ist die Lega
überall vertreten:
vom Stadtrat in Lugano
bis in den Tessiner Staatsrat.
Auch auf allen Stufen
der Einbürgerungsverfahren
trifft man auf Lega-Mitglieder.
Die harten Positionen der Partei
in Einwanderungsfragen
haben zu einer Verschärfung
der kantonalen Gesetze
über das Bürgerrecht geführt.
Die Anforderungen hier
gehen weit über die Kriterien
des Bundesgesetzes hinaus.
Sollte es hier schwieriger sein
als anderswo, Schweizer zu werden?
Die Lega ist nicht grundsätzlich
gegen die Einbürgerung.
Die Lega ist aber dagegen,
dass man Leuten den Schweizer Pass
schenkt, die ihn nicht verdienen.
Enea Petrini findet, dass man sich
den Schweizer Pass verdienen müsse.
Für Dawit und seine Familie
bedeutet das,
dass sie sich am Tag ihrer Anhörung
vor dem Kommissionspräsidenten
keine Fehler leisten dürfen.
Das Einbürgerungsgesuch hat Dawit
vor sechs Monaten eingereicht.
Seither wartet er auf das Aufgebot.
- Appetito!
Buon appetito, ragazzi.
- Buon appetito anche a te.
Wie ist das Schloss in Bellinzona?
Warst du gestern dort?
Das waren vielleicht viele Stufen.
Wir wurden gefragt,
wie wir rauf wollen.
Der Lehrer hat gefragt: "Wollt ihr
den Lift nehmen oder zu Fuss hoch?"
Wir alle: "Den Lift!"
Darauf der Lehrer:
"Gut, dann gehen alle zu Fuss."
Wir also rauf über die Treppe.
Daphné und ich waren ganz vorne.
Das war der Aufstieg zum Everest.
Oben angekommen
waren wir total erledigt.
Wie viele Stufen waren es denn?
- Keine Ahnung.
Sicher nicht mal 1 km,
vielleicht 100, 200 m - nicht mehr.
Warum wart ihr so müde, Kinder?
Ihr seid jung.
Als ich so alt war wie ihr, habe ich
jeden Tag 16 km zurückgelegt.
Zu Fuss?
- Ja, um in die Schule zu gehen.
Ich habe euch das schon mal erzählt:
8 km hin und 8 km zurück.
Und du behauptest, nach 5 Min.
Treppensteigen seist du erledigt.
Die Jugend von heute.
- Ja, die heutige Jugend.
Ich habe den Kindern auch gesagt,
was es für mich bedeutet,
eingebürgert zu werden.
Das ist mir wichtig,
ich fühle mich hier zu Hause.
Ich arbeite hier,
meine Kinder sind hier geboren.
Mein ganzes Leben
spielt sich hier ab.
Deshalb habe ich den Antrag gemacht.
Wo kommen die hin?
Der 63er kommt zu den WC-Wagen,
aber man kann nachher
hinunterfahren.
Die Leute
haben die nette Angewohnheit,
auf diese schönen dicken Kupplungen,
durch die viel Stromstärke fliesst,
zu pinkeln.
Das sollte man nicht meinen,
aber es ist tatsächlich so.
Ich würde es nicht machen -
zu gefährlich.
Nicht ganz die feine Schweizer Art.
Aber es bräuchte mehr,
um Andreas davon abzubringen,
Schweizer werden zu wollen.
Andreas Luther
stammt aus der ehemaligen DDR.
Die Schweiz war unerreichbar,
wie Amerika, Kanada oder Australien.
Die Schweiz war wie ein Traum.
Wie lange bist du schon hier?
- Seit 2006.
Ja, eben ...
Ich verstehe sehr gut, dass man nach
13 Jahren Schweizer werden will.
Die Bundesrepublik
interessiert mich nicht.
Mein Land, die DDR,
gibt es nicht mehr.
Hier in der Schweiz
fühle ich mich heimisch.
Die logische Konsequenz davon ist,
dass man versucht,
Staatsbürger zu werden,
die Staatsbürgerschaft beantragt
und versucht, das zu erreichen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Andreas und seine Familie
liessen sich vor 13 Jahren
am Ufer des Zürichsees nieder.
Wenn man so will,
auf der falschen Seite.
Sie konnten ja nicht wissen,
dass Freienbach zum eher
konservativen Kanton Schwyz gehört,
der mit am zurückhaltendsten
einbürgert.
Wie ich gehört habe, ist es
im Kanton Schwyz mit am schlimmsten.
Man hat ja auch Arbeitskollegen,
die das schon hinter sich haben,
aber eben in Zürich.
Wenn ich mir das so anhöre ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
In Zürich springt man
über ein so kleines Stöckchen
und in Freienbach
über eine 3 m hohe Mauer.
Andreas weiss, wovon er redet.
Seine Tochter
ist gegen die Mauer gerannt.
Sie war vor fünf Jahren
die Erste der Familie,
die sich einbürgern lassen wollte.
Ihre Anhörung erlebte sie
wie einen Albtraum.
Da war sie gerade 20 Jahre alt.
Sie ist jetzt Flugbegleiterin,
mein Töchterchen, ganz klein.
Bei meiner Tochter
hat es nicht geklappt.
Ich finde es traurig für sie,
dass es nicht geklappt hat.
Aber es entmutigt mich nicht.
Sie hätte es
weiter versuchen können.
Aber sie hat
die Konsequenzen gezogen
und ging zurück nach Deutschland.
Tochter Lisa hatte ihre Jugendzeit
in Freienbach verbracht.
Die abschlägige Antwort
empfand sie als komplette Ablehnung.
Daraufhin
kehrte sie der Schweiz den Rücken.
Zurück blieb Andreas mit seinem
Wunsch, Schweizer zu werden.
In sieben Monaten
wird er vor demselben Gremium stehen,
das seine Tochter abgewiesen hat.
Um jemanden abzulehnen,
braucht es schon
ziemlich starke Gründe:
z.B. nicht zu wissen,
dass Etzel unser Hausberg ist,
oder nicht zu wissen,
wie die Anlage heisst,
in der die Anhörung stattfindet.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Annina Herrmann
war bei Lisas Anhörung mit dabei.
Zu den Gründen,
weshalb Lisa gescheitert ist,
will sie nichts sagen.
Sie verweist
auf die Bestimmungen der Gemeinde.
Die Gegend ist sehr schön
und der Flughafen Zürich ist nahe.
Die Schulen und Ausbildungsstätten
sind sehr gut.
Das sind Kriterien, warum viele
in den Kanton Schwyz kommen.
Gut!
(Alle) # Oh, du goldigs Sünneli,
tuen doch wider schiine!
Im wohlhabenden Freienbach
stammt ein Drittel
der Einwohnerschaft aus dem Ausland.
Annina Herrmann
wohnt seit über 30 Jahren hier.
Die pensionierte Pflegefachfrau macht
beim generationenübergreifenden
Projekt
Senioren in der Kinderkrippe mit.
Roman, du bist ein Schlaumeier,
du weisst, wie es geht.
Ja!
Meine Kinder sind bald 30 Jahre alt.
Als sie hier in den Kindergarten
und in die Schule gingen,
gab es fast keine Ausländerkinder
in den Klassen.
Das hat sich stark verändert.
Eine erfolgreiche Integration
ist abhängig von der Sprache.
Im Kindergarten hatten wir bereits
bis zu acht
verschiedene Nationalitäten.
Es gibt z.B. Kinder,
die die Sprache noch nicht können,
wenn sie kommen.
Fokus.
- Hokus, nicht Fokus, Hokus!
Hokuspokus, simsalabim!
Einige dieser Kinder -
sollten sie sich irgendwann
einbürgern lassen wollen -
finden sich vielleicht dereinst
vor Annina Herrmann wieder.
Das Gesetz sieht die Möglichkeit vor,
dass Minderjährige ab zwölf Jahren
alleine angehört werden können.
Einbürgern lassen
wollen sich Schüler
wie auch 60-Jährige,
die sich plötzlich dazu entscheiden.
Der Schweizer Pass
ist nach wie vor sehr beliebt.
Für einen
so begehrten Schweizer Pass
kann man sich mal ein paar Stunden
hinsetzen und dafür lernen.
So! Ich beginne
mit Geografie, Geschichte, Sprache -
das war der erste Kursabend.
Da gibt es Grundwissen.
Nationalfeiertag ist am 1. August.
Dann die Fläche, etwa ...
In der Vorbereitung
für Einbürgerungswillige
ist Andreas
an seinem sechsten und letzten Kurs.
Wie die anderen Bewerbenden
bereitet er sich auf den
kantonalen Einbürgerungstest vor.
In Freienbach
ist das Bestehen des Tests
Voraussetzung
für die Aufnahme des Verfahrens.
Anzahl Kantone?
Sie können sieben, acht davon
mit Abkürzungen aufzählen?
SG steht für ...
- (Mehrere) St. Gallen.
ZH?
- Zürich.
UR?
- Uri.
VS?
- Wallis.
ZK? Gibt es nicht!
Gut!
Durch welche Seen fliesst der Rhein?
Hinten haben Sie
eine grosse Schweizerkarte.
Man muss viel lernen,
aber das ist ganz in Ordnung.
Die Aare fliesst dort durch Bern.
Es ist
ein gegenseitiges Nehmen und Geben:
Ich möchte etwas
und muss etwas dafür tun.
Einfach so wäre es wie zugeworfen.
Man würde es wohl nicht so schätzen,
wie wenn man
es selber geschafft hat.
Demokratie und Föderalismus.
Nationalrat, Ständerat: Wen ver-
treten Nationalräte und -rätinnen?
Die Bevölkerung.
- Die Bevölkerung.
Bevölkerungsreiche Kantone
haben viele Vertreterinnen,
bevölkerungsarme Kantone
haben weniger.
Wen vertreten die Ständeräte?
Ich finde es sehr gut,
dass man sich über das Land,
die Bildung, die Kultur informiert.
Man sollte Bescheid darüber wissen,
was Schweizer in der Schule lernen.
Verspüren Sie jetzt Nachteile
ohne den Schweizer Pass?
Sozial eigentlich nicht,
aber man wird fremdbestimmt.
Man hat
kein eigenes Mitspracherecht.
Ja.
Wir können Wohnungen kaufen,
alles machen.
Aber wir können nicht sagen, welche
Politiker im Parlament sitzen.
Das Gefühl,
dass wir jetzt abstimmen dürfen.
Viele machen vielleicht erstmals
ein Kreuz auf einen Wahlzettel
eines direktdemokratischen Systems.
Wir sind jetzt Teil dieser Menge.
Das ist eine Gefühlssache.
Sie durchlaufen
einen technischen Prozess.
Trotzdem geht es auch
um viele Gefühle,
um eine Herzensangelegenheit.
Eine tolle Antwort, schön.
Das schaffen wir!
Willkommen
bei der Einbürgerungsstelle,
die von der Stadt Lausanne
betrieben wird.
Das Angebot
ist für Einwohner/-innen,
die sich in Lausanne
einbürgern lassen wollen, kostenlos.
In Lausanne wird
kein schriftlicher Test durchgeführt.
Entscheidend ist die Anhörung
vor der Gemeinde.
Alle in diesem Saal haben ihr Gesuch
vor der Anpassung des Bundesgesetzes
über das Schweizer Bürgerrecht 2018
eingereicht.
Seither wurde das Gesetz verschärft:
Wer den Schweizer Pass will,
braucht mindestens einen C-Ausweis,
zehn Jahre Aufenthalt im Land,
schriftliche und mündliche
Sprachkenntnisse
und darf während dreier Jahre
vor der Gesucheinreichung
keine Sozialhilfe bezogen haben.
Viele würden diese neuen Bedingungen
nicht erfüllen.
Um ein Scheitern zu vermeiden,
setzen die Bewerber/-innen
auf das Ausbildner-Ehepaar
Brigitte und Douglas Gonzalez.
Wir gehören zum Massnahmenpaket,
das für die Kandidierenden
geschnürt wurde, damit sie bestehen.
Und für uns ist es Teil
unserer Bürgerpflicht.
Brigitte und Douglas,
venezolanisch-schweizerische
Doppelbürger,
haben selbst das
Einbürgerungsverfahren durchlaufen.
Nachdem sie sich
in Lausanne niedergelassen hatten,
haben sie sich aktiv
um ihre Integration bemüht.
Um künftige Mitbürger
zu unterstützen,
setzen sie all ihre Energie
für das Coachen ein.
Wie wird die Anhörung vor der
Einbürgerungskommission ablaufen?
Ihnen werden Fragen zum politischen
System der Schweiz gestellt,
zur Geografie und zur Geschichte.
Wer weiss, wo sich das Bundesamt
für Gesundheit befindet?
Vous avez une idée?
- Non.
Es gibt alle erdenklichen Profile:
von der Analphabetin,
die als Haushälterin arbeitet,
zum Doktor in Philosophie, der
an der ETH Lausanne unterrichtet.
Die Palette ist riesig.
Die Gemeinde bildet den Kern.
Sind Sie für oder gegen
das Bundesgesetz
über die Steuerreform
und die AHV-Finanzierung?
Es sind Menschen,
die den ganzen Tag arbeiten
und um 18 Uhr müde nach Hause
kommen. Man sieht es ihnen an.
Das ist alles so kompliziert
und doch müssen sie es wissen.
Wir wissen nicht, welche Fragen
man ihnen stellen wird,
aber wir versuchen, sie
so gut wie möglich vorzubereiten,
damit sie auf jede Frage
eine Antwort haben.
Wie heisst die Präsidentin
des Waadtländer Staatsrats?
Gorrite, ja.
Wer vertritt die Exekutive
im Kanton Waadt?
Der Staatsrat.
- Wie viele Sitze hat er?
Sieben.
- Können Sie sie aufzählen?
(Douglas) Bevor sie
ihr Gesuch eingereicht haben,
hat man diesen Menschen gesagt,
dass die Politik nichts für sie sei,
weil sie Ausländer sind.
Und jetzt plötzlich müssen sie
das fehlende Wissen nachbüffeln.
(Brigitte) Wo haben die ersten
Eidgenossen ihren Schwur abgelegt?
Brütli?
- Ce n'est pas Brütli, c'est Rütli.
Rütli - ich habe es falsch gelesen.
Auf der Rütliwiese, genau.
Wer war Wilhelm Tell?
Das ist schwierig.
Der Mann,
der mit der Armbrust einen Pfeil
durch einen Apfel geschossen hat,
der auf dem Kopf seines Sohnes lag.
Sagt das niemandem was?
Napoleon?
- Napoleon?
* Lachen *
Nein, nicht Napoleon,
der war Franzose.
In welcher Stadt
befindet sich der Bärengraben?
(Mehrere) Bern.
- Genau.
Wie starb Major Davel?
- (Mehrere) Er wurde geköpft.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Wenn's nach mir ginge,
bekämen Sie alle den Schweizer Pass.
Merci, au revoir.
- Service. A vendredi. Au revoir.
Die Leute haben Angst.
Seit 40 Jahren haben sie
keine Schulbank mehr gedrückt.
Dann sollen sie plötzlich
eine Prüfung bestehen.
Schon allein die Tatsache, dass sie
vor einer Kommission stehen,
versetzt sie in Angst und Schrecken.
Vieles weiss ich ja schon,
trotzdem bin ich etwas angespannt.
Tina Turner ist Schweizerin.
Okay.
- Okay, sie ist Amerikanerin.
Sie ist vor Millionen von Menschen
aufgetreten.
Aber trotzdem hatte sie nie zuvor
so viel Angst im Leben
wie an dem Tag, an dem sie
für die Einbürgerung angehört wurde.
Tina Turner!
* Schwebende Klänge *
Bist du nervös?
- Ein bisschen.
Wir sind gut vorbereitet.
Und wenn alles gut geht, sollte das
keine grosse Sache werden.
Was denkst du?
- Wir werden sehen.
Gehen wir, meine Liebe.
Sitzt mein Hemd hinten richtig?
- Ja, ja.
Ich habe mich für den Sitz in der
Einbürgerungskommission beworben,
weil ich den Kontakt mit Menschen
schätze.
Menschen kennenlernen und mit ihnen
diskutieren, das gefällt mir.
Ich weiss noch:
Als ich in die Schweiz kam,
fand ich die Waadtländer sehr ernst.
Ich fand es am Anfang schwierig, mit
den Lausannern in Kontakt zu kommen.
Die Leute hier sind
etwas zurückhaltender, finde ich.
* Treibende elektronische Musik *
Ich bin Doppelbürgerin:
Französin und Schweizerin.
Ich habe in Dijon studiert und dann
einen Schweizer kennengelernt.
Wir haben geheiratet
und ich bin nach Lausanne gezogen.
Das war 1973.
Damals war das Gesetz anders.
Wenn eine Frau
einen Schweizer heiratete,
wurde sie automatisch Schweizerin.
Bonjour!
Der Schweizer Pass war also
gewissermassen Teil der Mitgift.
Diesen Menschen muss man mit einer
gewissen Seriosität begegnen,
ihnen gegenüber
angemessen auftreten.
Mir ist natürlich bewusst,
dass es für sie um viel geht.
Hier entscheidet sich alles.
Können wir, meine Damen und Herren?
Bonjour, Madame.
- Bonjour, Madame.
Prenez place de ce côté.
Obwohl
das italienisch-spanische Rentnerpaar
schon seit gut 60 Jahren
in der Schweiz lebt,
fällt der Entscheid
über seine Einbürgerung
hier vor dieser Kommission,
in nur 20 Min.
Wir von der Einbürgerungskommission
heissen Sie willkommen.
Bevor wir
zum eigentlichen Thema kommen,
wollen wir wissen, weshalb Sie sich
einbürgern lassen wollen,
Herr di Giandomenico.
Um mich als echter Schweizer Bürger
zu fühlen.
Weil wir seit 60 Jahren
immer etwas abseits stehen,
bei den Abstimmungen und auch sonst.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen,
Frau di Giandomenico?
Unsere Kinder sind Schweizer,
unsere Enkelkinder auch.
Warum sollten nicht auch wir
uns einbürgern lassen?
Ich lebe seit meinem 18. Lebensjahr
in der Schweiz
und habe mein Leben lang gearbeitet.
Ja, Sie haben immer gearbeitet.
Auch als die Kinder klein waren.
Sehr gut,
dann fangen wir mit den Fragen an.
Beginnen wir mit Geschichte,
einverstanden?
Sagt Ihnen der Name Major Davel
etwas?
Er hat versucht,
eine Revolution gegen ...
... die Berner anzuzetteln.
Er wurde geköpft.
Aber der Kanton Waadt
wurde dann doch unabhängig.
In welchem Jahr?
- 1788.
1798.
- Genau 1798, Entschuldigung.
Am 24. Januar 1798.
Monsieur,
nun zur Schweizer Geschichte.
Es gibt eine erste Bundesverfassung.
Wissen Sie, von wann
diese erste Bundesverfassung stammt?
Das war 1874.
Das war die zweite.
Und die erste?
1848.
- Genau, 1848. Das war die erste.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass alle Schweizer das wissen.
Aber wir verlangen
von den Ausländern,
die sich dieser Prüfung stellen,
dass sie das wissen.
Das ist ziemlich anspruchsvoll.
Ich gebe meinem Kollegen das Wort
für die weiteren Themen.
Ich schlage vor,
dass wir mit den politischen
Institutionen weitermachen.
Minuten werden zur Ewigkeit.
Die Angst vor dem entscheidenden
Fehler ist jederzeit spürbar.
Aus wie vielen Kammern
besteht das Parlament
auf Stufe Bundesversammlung?
Aus zwei Kammern.
- Genau.
Und wie heissen
diese beiden Kammern?
Der Staatsrat.
Der Ständerat.- Ah, ja.
Der Ständerat hat 46 Sitze.
Bevor ich Mitglied
der Einbürgerungskommission wurde,
wusste ich nicht, wie viele
National- oder Ständeräte es gibt.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung.
Hätte ich den Test machen müssen,
wäre ich ganz sicher durchgefallen.
Worin besteht der Unterschied
zwischen einem Referendum
und einer Initiative?
Wer beginnt?
Mit einem Referendum stösst man
ein Gesetz an. Und dann ...
Ich habe gehört,
wie Ihre Frau Nein gesagt hat.
Bitte korrigieren Sie und dann
komme ich wieder zu Ihnen zurück.
Man ergreift ein Referendum,
um gegen ein beschlossenes Gesetz
vorzugehen.
Es ist normal,
dass dieses Wissen verlangt wird.
Nicht normal ist, dass die meisten
Schweizer all das nicht wissen.
Welche Farben
hat das Wappen von Lausanne?
Weiss und rot.
Genau,
und das Wappen des Kantons Waadt?
Weiss und grün.
- Das ist richtig.
Damit wäre das Gespräch zu Ende.
Wir zwei beraten uns jetzt
und fällen unseren Entscheid,
den Sie dann
von der Gemeinde erhalten.
Bei einem positiven Entscheid
geht Ihr Dossier an den Kanton
und dann weiter an den Bund.
Sie brauchen etwas Geduld, denn es
dauert dann noch eineinhalb Jahre,
bis Sie den Schweizer Pass erhalten.
Vielen Dank.
Anderthalb Jahre im besten Fall,
denn das Bundesgesetz
setzt keine Fristen,
es gibt nur Empfehlungen ab.
Au revoir, merci.
Die Stadt Lausanne
verpflichtet sich immerhin,
den Entscheid bis sechs Wochen
nach der Anhörung bekannt zu geben.
Ich glaube,
es ist ganz gut gelaufen.
Aber der Entscheid
liegt doch bei ihnen, nicht?
Ja, noch ist nichts entschieden.
Aber wir haben uns gut geschlagen.
Die Einbürgerungskommission
von Lausanne
hat uns
die einmalige Gelegenheit gegeben,
mit der Kamera
an ihrer Beratung dabei zu sein.
Wir gehen die Punkte durch: Be-
herrschen der französischen Sprache?
Er spricht sehr gut Französisch.
Er hat die Fragen perfekt verstanden
und uns korrekt geantwortet.
Sehr gut, ja. Und sie auch.
Integration?
Integration: gut. Man merkt, dass
sie immer in Lausanne gelebt haben.
Sie besitzen eine Wohnung,
haben zwei erwachsene Kinder,
die virtuos Akkordeon spielen -
eine echte Erfolgsgeschichte.
Dann schreiben wir
perfekt integriert.
Perfekt integriert.
- Bei beiden?
Genau.
- Einverstanden.
Kenntnisse der Geschichte?
Sie ausgezeichnet, er etwas weniger.
Sagen wir sehr gut.
Bei der Anspannung
konnte er wohl nicht
all seine Fähigkeiten und Kenntnisse
einbringen.
Wir können sehr gut setzen.
- Dann sind wir uns einig, gut.
Der Vorentscheid fällt damit
positiv aus. - Ist notiert.
Éliane Aubert und ihr Kollege
gehen zum nächsten Dossier über.
Die Zeit drängt: Bis Ende des Jahres
muss die Kommission zwingend
alle 1'600 Bewerbungsdossiers
abarbeiten,
die noch unter dem alten Gesetz
eingereicht wurden.
Um dieses Ziel zu erreichen,
arbeitet die zehnköpfige Kommission
in Zweierteams,
die sich täglich abwechseln.
Die Ausländer/-innen in Lausanne
haben ein Schreiben
der Stadtverwaltung bekommen,
in dem erklärt wurde,
dass es eine neue,
strengere Einbürgerungsgesetzgebung
gebe.
Wir haben ihnen damals empfohlen,
das Gesuch vor dem 31. Dezember 2017
einzureichen,
damit das Dossier gemäss
dem alten Gesetz behandelt wird,
was die Einbürgerung erleichtert.
Bevor sie von der Einbürgerungs-
kommission angehört werden,
müssen die Bewerber aber erst
eine andere Hürde nehmen.
Ana und Paolo haben nun endlich
alle Dokumente beisammen,
die sie für das Verfahren benötigen.
Nach all den Jahren habe ich jetzt
alle Unterlagen, die ich brauche.
Hier.
- Eheurkunde.
2016 hatten wir schon
alle Unterlagen vorbereitet.
Dann kam jedoch
die schlimme Nachricht,
nämlich Paolos Krebsdiagnose.
Dann verging die Zeit
und alle Dokumente liefen ab.
Dann musste ich wieder
von Neuem anfangen.
Die Kopie.
- Deine und die von Chiara.
In der ganzen Schweiz
ist es dasselbe Geduldsspiel,
bis der Papierkram erledigt ist und
alle benötigten Unterlagen vorliegen:
Niederlassungsbewilligung,
Identitätsausweise,
Strafregisterauszug,
Sprachnachweis, Leumundszeugnis,
Betreibungsregisterauszug, Lohnaus-
weise, Personenstandsregisterauszug,
Steuererklärung, Referenzen und meist
auch noch ein Bewerbungsschreiben.
Das ist nicht nichts.
Schau, wie viele!
Aber jetzt habe ich alle beisammen.
Überall in der Schweiz sieht die
Einbürgerungspraxis etwas anders aus.
Im Tessin
muss man einen Test bestehen,
den man nach einem obligatorischen
40-stündigen Kurs ablegen kann.
In Schwyz
steht es den Gemeinden frei,
einen kantonalen Test zu verlangen.
Die Bewerbenden müssen aber
eine Selbsteinschätzung
zu ihrer Integration ausfüllen.
Ich habe
ein regelmässiges Einkommen,
habe keine Sozialhilfe bezogen.
Ich habe kein Verbrechen
oder Vergehen begangen
oder eine Busse über 1'000 Fr.
erhalten.
Während Andreas
kopfschüttelnd das Formular ausfüllt,
brauchen Corona-Cardosos
in Pontresina ihr Dossier
nur noch zur Post zu bringen, damit
das Verfahren seinen Lauf nimmt.
Wir haben alles beisammen.
- Abwarten.
Für Dawit
hat die Dauer des Verfahrens Folgen.
Als Flüchtling kann er nicht
nach Eritrea zurück.
Seine Kinder haben weder ihre Heimat
noch ihre Verwandten dort je gesehen.
Seit 13 Jahren sehnt sich Dawit nach
einem Wiedersehen mit seinem Vater.
Ohne Pass ist daran nicht zu denken.
* Freizeichen *
(Mann) Hallo?
Papa?
- Hallo!
Wie geht's?
Es geht, aber ich werde langsam alt.
Das sagst du schon lange.
Dawit, mein Sohn,
immerhin bin ich jetzt 85.
Gut, die Kinder sind hier bei mir,
ich gebe dir Ermiyas.
Wie geht es dir?
Mir geht es gut, Kleiner,
aber ihr fehlt mir sehr.
Heute ist ein gesegneter Tag,
es ist ein gesegneter Sonntag.
Gott sei Dank.
Das ist gut, mein Sohn.
Mein einziger Wunsch ist, dich
wiederzusehen, bevor es zu spät ist.
Ausgeschlossen, dass du uns
verlässt. Du wirst 90 Jahre alt.
Das Wichtigste ist,
dass ich dich wiedersehe.
Ich wünsche mir nur das.
Amen, amen, Papa.
Leg auf,
das Gespräch wird sonst zu teuer.
In Ordnung, Papa,
ich rufe dich bald wieder an.
Einverstanden, Sohn, in Ordnung.
Eh, si.
Mein Vater ist 85 Jahre alt.
Er kann nicht in die Schweiz reisen
und ich kann nicht zurück
nach Eritrea.
Das betrifft nicht nur mich,
sondern alle, die in der Schweiz
Asyl beantragt haben.
Die,
die nach Schweden oder Norwegen,
nach Finnland, in die Niederlande
oder nach Grossbritannien gehen,
haben nach fünf oder sechs Jahren
einen Pass
und können nach Eritrea zurück.
Deshalb fragt mich mein Vater
immer wieder:
"Dawit, warum kommst du nicht?"
Ihn umarmen zu können, fehlt mir,
sein Lachen zu sehen.
Mir ist das sehr wichtig.
Ich würde ihn gerne sehen,
bevor er stirbt.
Ich weiss, dass es passieren wird,
aber ich hoffe,
dass er nicht jetzt geht,
nicht, bevor wir ihn besucht haben.
Mir kommt es vor wie beim Eislaufen.
Die Pflichtmodule
haben wir hinter uns
und am Dienstag kommt Ihre Kür.
Wie steht's um Ihren Puls?
Auf einer Skala von 0-10?
Zehn wäre sehr nervös
und null ganz relaxed.
Frau Tomczak?
Ziemlich hoch, würde ich sagen.
- Was ist der Grund dafür?
Ich glaube, die Wichtigkeit
dieser Prüfung für uns alle.
Gut.
Nervös? Man hofft das Beste.
Am Montag ist frei und da kann man
die drei Tage intensiv nutzen.
Gut, noch etwas?
Wir schaffen das alle.
Gut, danke.
- Danke auch.
* Treibende Musik *
Alles Gute und viel Erfolg.
Andreas stellt sich den 50 Fragen
des Einbürgerungstests
des Kantons Schwyz.
Scheitert er, wird
das gesamte Verfahren eingestellt.
Dawit hat
einen befristeten Arbeitsvertrag.
Er hofft, bald einen unbefristeten
von seinem Arbeitgeber zu bekommen.
Denn sonst erfüllt er eine Voraus-
setzung für die Einbürgerung nicht:
Jeder Bewerber muss für sich
und seine Familie aufkommen können.
Während Ana und Paolo arbeiten,
prüfen die Bündner Behörden
ihr Dossier auf Herz und Nieren.
Beim kleinsten Makel
geht es an die Absender zurück
und das Spiel beginnt von vorn.
In Lausanne folgt eine Anhörung
auf die andere, ohne Pause.
Gerade ist das Ehepaar Sivanesan
aus Sri Lanka an der Reihe,
sich den Fragen der
Einbürgerungskommission zu stellen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2020